so I have two conversion scenarios right
over here I want to convert three
kilograms into milligrams and I want to
convert four tons into ounces so this is
clearly in the metric system and this
right over here is in the US customary
system so I encourage you to pause this
video and try to do these conversions on
your own well to think about this one we
just have to think about what these what
these prefixes mean so I could rewrite
it this this is three kilograms
kilograms and we're going to convert
into some amount of milligrams
milligrams and we've already seen that
the prefix kilo this literally means
1000 this means 1000 and the prefix
milli the prefix milli means 1 over a
thousand or one thousandth of a gram so
let's just convert to grams first let's
go from kilograms to grams and then we
can go from grams to milligrams so we
could say that three kilograms three
kilograms is going to be equal to three
times 1,000 three times 1,000 grams
three times 1,000 grams so that's three
thousand grams so this is equal to three
thousand three thousand grams this is
literally three thousand grams that's
one way to interpret kilo so this gets
us to three thousand grams now how do we
go from the grams to the milligrams well
we already said we already said right
over here that one milligram let me
write it if your 1 milligram is equal to
one over a thousand or one thousandth of
a gram but another way of thinking about
this statement is that one gram is equal
to one thousand milligrams so if we keep
this in mind we have three thousand
grams each of those are going to be
equal to one thousand milligrams so this
is equal to three thousand three
thousand grams each of those are
equivalent to one thousand milligrams so
times 1000 times 1000 and this is going
to give us the number of milligrams
and what is this going to be well three
thousand one thousand a thousand
thousands is a million so three thousand
thousands is three million so this is
going to get us three million three
million milligrams another way to think
about this multiplication I've got I've
got three zeros here three zeros here so
my final product should so 3 times 1 is
3 and then I should follow that with the
6 0 so I get 3 million milligrams now
let's do the same thing over here let's
convert this this US customary ton right
over here to ounces and what we'll do
first is we'll go 2 pounds and then from
pounds we can go 2 ounces and we know we
know that 1 ton is equal to 2,000 2,000
pounds
so 4 tons 4 tonnes are going to be equal
to well each of those are going to be
2,000 pounds it's going to be 4 times
2,000 pounds which is equal to 8,000
pounds 8,000 make sure have some space
here 8,000 pounds 8,000 pounds now how
many how many Ounces are in each of
those pounds well we know that 1 pound
we know that 1 pound is equal to 16
ounces so 8,000 pounds so this over here
so let me write this so 8,000 pounds
8,000 pounds if each of those 8,000 has
16 ounces are equivalent to 16 ounces
this is going to be 8,000 times 16
ounces so what is 8,000 times 16 so this
is going to be let's see 8 times 16 is
80 plus 48 is 128 but then that's not 8
we want to do 8,000 times so it's going
to be 128 thousand one hundred and
twenty-eight thousand ounces so four
tonnes are a lot of ounces